jetzt also doch geheim und überraschend
hier ein großer Bahnhof in Kiew am
frühen Morgen trifft der Bundespräsident
Frank-Walter Steinmeier am Hauptbahnhof
der ukrainischen Hauptstadt ein ja ein
Besuch mit sehr viel Brisanz seit Beginn
des Ukraine Krieges wird der
Bundespräsident ja immer wieder für
seine langjährige russlandfreundliche
Politik kritisiert und erst letzte Woche
hatte er ja aus Sicherheitsgründen schon
einen geplanten Besuch abgesagt
in der Dunkelheit erreicht Frank-Walter
Steinmeier mit dem Zug die ukrainische
Hauptstadt Kiel es ist die erste Ukraine
Reise des Bundespräsidenten seit dem
Beginn des russischen Angriffskrieges am
24 Februar
meine Botschaft an die Ukrainerinnen und
Ukrainer ist wir stehen nicht nur an
eurer Seite sondern wir werden die
Ukraine auch weiterhin unterstützen
wirtschaftlich politisch
und auch militärisch es ist bereits
Steinmeiers dritte Anlauf eines
Staatsbesuchs bereits Mitte April gab es
kurz vor der reisestein Meiers eine
Absage aus Kiew der deutsche
Bundespräsident ausgeladen mutmaßlich
wegen seiner jahrzehntelangen Russland
Kuschelei die zweite geplante Reise in
der vergangenen Woche wurde aus
Sicherheitsgründen vom Bundeskriminalamt
verschoben angesichts der aktuellen
Gefahrenlage gemeint wiederholte
russische Attacken mit Drohnen und
Raketen auf die ukrainische Hauptstadt
an der Gefahrenlage hat sich seitdem
nichts geändert dennoch nun der
überraschende Besuch mir war es wichtig
gerade jetzt in dieser Phase der
Luftangriffe mit Drohnen maßloskörpern
und Raketen ein Zeichen der Solidarität
an die Ukrainerinnen und Ukrainer zu
senden
Solidarität oder zu großer politischer
Druck auf Steinmeier vor dem
Bundespräsidenten liegt ein straffes
Programm geplant ist ein Treffen mit
Präsident wollladimir selenski sowie ein
Besuch zurückeroberter Gebiete in der
nordukraine
Björn Städte unser Bild Reporter ist
jetzt genau da wo Herr Steinmeier heute
morgen eingetroffen ist nämlich am
Hauptbahnhof in Kiew Björn klär uns mal
auf erst aus Sicherheitsgründen abgesagt
nun wolle er ein Zeichen setzen was ist
denn jetzt die Wahrheit und warum hat er
sich dann doch umentschieden
also ich glaube dass die Absage aus
Sicherheitsgründen tatsächlich
vielleicht tatsächlich von seinem
Sicherheitsteam mit mit der mit dem
realen Verweis auf auf diese Drohnen und
Raketenangriffe die Kiew getroffen haben
das ist also tatsächlich schon
tatsächlich der Grund war allerdings zur
selben Zeit sind natürlich andere
Spitzenpolitiker in Kiew eingetroffen
aber seinen Sicherheitsteam mag dazu
einer anderen Bewertung der Lage
gekommen sein jedenfalls jetzt ist er
eingetroffen hat angekündigt auch hier
ein Zeichen setzen zu wollen gerade
angesichts dieser Lage auch wenn die
sich in Kiew natürlich ein wenig
beruhigt hat und insofern ja ich glaube
das sollte man ihm bei aller Kritik die
die ihn zurecht trifft auch zugestehen
dass da dass er sein Sicherheitsteam zu
dieser Einschätzung gekommen ist ganz
oben auf der Agenda des
Bundespräsidenten natürlich eintreffen
mit der Ukraine ist Präsident selenski
was glaubst Du genau wird da besprochen
wird da auch noch mal um weitere
Waffenlieferungen oder ähnliches gehen
also den Wunsch wird der ukrainische
Präsident sicher vortragen aber
in unserem politischen System hat der
Bundespräsident eine wenig andere
Stellung insofern glaube ich deshalb
keine Detailfragen besprochen werden
eben weil der der Bundespräsident ja
nicht ja weil nicht Teil solcher
exekutiventscheidungen der der
Bundesregierung ist aber natürlich wird
es sozusagen vorgetragen werden dass das
die Ukraine sich von Deutschland
weiterhin politische politische
wirtschaftliche und militärische Hilfe
wünscht und das hat Steinmeier auch bei
seinem Eintreffen hier erklärt dass er
dass das Deutschland das weiterhin
leisten werde interessanter finde ich
eher noch die Frage wie er selber darauf
reagieren wird bei seinem Auftakt hier
heute hat er keinerlei Worte
Selbstkritik verloren und wir erinnern
uns daran so dass politische Lebenswerk
des Außenministers Frank-Walter
Steinmeier war im Prinzip darauf
ausgerichtet dieses russische Regime
immer weiter zu ermutigen bis es
letztendlich
auch zu diesem Angriff auf die Ukraine
gekommen ist also er hat
immer wieder Versuche das appeasements
unternommen nach der nach der Invasion
2014 er hat Putin ist Putin immer wieder
entgegengekommen als dieser Terror
Bomber de Maus in in Syrien ausgeübt hat
als er dort Aleppo zerstört hat als er
dort hunderttausende in den Tod und in
die Flucht gebombt hat und letztendlich
wird es zumindest für mich die
interessante Frage sein ob Steinmeier
dann auch beim beim Gespräch mit
silenskörper da zumindest auch die
persönliche Verantwortung übernimmt im
persönlichen Wort der Entschuldigung
oder bzw um Verzeihung dafür bittet für
seine Fehler glaubst du denn dass
selensky das möchte dass es wichtig wäre
für die Ukraine und auch ja für die
Beziehungen der Ukraine zu Deutschland
das diese Entschuldigung tatsächlich
kommt
wichtiger als eine solche Entschuldigung
sind natürlich praktische Taten also
endlich Hilfe zum Beispiel bei
Schützenpanzern bei Kampfpanzern die
Ukraine wird auf absehbare Zeit
westliche Kampfpanzer dringend benötigen
einfach weil die alten sowjetischen
Systeme die Sie diese benutzen
irgendwann ja für die kann die können
irgendwann nicht mehr instand gesetzt
werden die werden nicht mehr produziert
insofern ist solche tatkräftige Hilfe
deutlich wichtiger aber ich glaube es
ist auch ein
zumindest für die für die
deutsch-ukrainischen Beziehungen
durchaus wichtig wäre dass er ein
solches Signal das
der Einsicht der Selbstreflexion der
selbstkritikauf von Steinmeier kommt und
zwar eine die auch in persönlich
betrifft denn er hat als Außenminister
sehr viele Fehlentscheidungen getroffen
die letztendlich Russland in diesem Jahr
zu diesem Angriffskrieg ermutigt haben
wir sind gespannt wie sich Frank-Walter
Steinmeier dann tatsächlich bei seinem
Besuch geben wird du wirst diesen Besuch
natürlich für uns begleiten weiterhin
Dankeschön Björn erstmal danke an dich
Björn
[Musik]